[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
علاقه الشجر والبشر والحشر بالمناخ علاقه
تلازوميه وعلىماتها يستدل بها على المواسم
فاختفاء الزواحف دليل على بدايه البرد
وتطليع النخيل وظهور الحشرات دليل على
بدايه الربيع اذا طلعت البرنيه اطلع
بالحوش بدون بطانيه وكثره الذباب سنه
الربيعيه وكثره الجراد سنه مجذبه اللهم
اجعلها سنه ضباب ولا تجعلها سنه تجرات
وظهور الوزغ والحيايا والعقارب والثعابين
وجميع الهوام السامه دليل على بدايه الحرب
والوزق الرقه على ذولها تطعم الحياه في
الجحر والخنفس الاسود من نجله موده العقرب
في السري
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وخلال هذه الايام تختفي الزواحف والعقارب
والثعابين وجميع الهوام السامه وهذا دليل
على بدايه البوادر الشتويه وتظل مختبئه
وكامنه في جحورها لمده ثلاثه شهور تقريبا
ولا تطلع وتظهر الا مع بدايه البوادر
الصيفيه واول ما يختفي منها المسن واول ما
يظهر منها الصغير لا تامن العقرب ولا تامن
الداب السم واحد لا رجاء في متونك يا جاهل
الدنيا ودورات الاسباب اعرف ترى من خان
غيرك يخونك
[موسيقى]